Now let's come back to aesthetics.
I mentioned this at the start, and I wanted to see how some two, in particular,
two classical authors have kind of captured the notion of aesthetics and
what relationship that might have to software design.
The first is Aquinas.
I won't quote for you the, the Latin but what it, what it boils down to
is that beauty, elegance, resolve to wholeness, harmony and radiance.
And we can think of that as far as software is concerned as completeness,
consistency and conceptual integrity.
Other quote comes from Pascal,
you may have heard of the Pascal programming language.
Pascal was a French mathematician, and one of my favorite quotes is he said,
he apologized in a letter saying, sorry I didn't have I would have
written you a shorter letter, but I didn't have time.
If you think about it for a minute, what this means is it takes a lot of
time and energy to come up with an elegant solution that looks quite simple on
the surface, but really satisfies the complex requirements.